a dozen Nations say they're interested
in joining bricks the block of the
world's leading emerging market
economies is becoming increasingly
attractive to up-and-coming countries
and those wanting a greater say in
global politics the world is changed
dramatically over the past 70 or 80
years since we founded the United
Nations system and the Bretton Woods
system and what was then the get and now
the WTO
all of these institutions need reforming
and we are saying that the reform
process must take into account the
position and voices of the global South
we need policy space to also make a
determination on how this new order
should be shaped in an inclusive manner
a year ago during a virtual Summit
hosted in China President Vladimir Putin
said Russia was ready to further develop
its cooperation with Brazil India China
and South Africa in the block
but after Russia's invasion of Ukraine
its relationship with South Africa has
come under scrutiny from Western Powers
the U.S has accused Pretoria of
supplying arms to Russia it denies that
and says it's investigating it's
expected the inquiry may take up to six
weeks or potentially longer to complete
some analysts are concerned South
Africa's relations with the United
States and the European Union may be
badly impacted if it has indeed supplied
arms to Russia but South Africa
maintains its neutral on the issue of
the Ukraine conflict in a meeting with
Russian foreign minister Sergey lavrov
South Africa's international relations
Minister naledi Pando defended holding
military exercises with Russia saying
they were routine that's further
strained relations with the country's
important trading partner the United
States it's a position that they have to
negotiate very carefully and it is a
balancing act they need to be very
careful because of course Europe remains
still our biggest trade partner so you
don't want to annoy Europe too much then
again China and India together is almost
double the amount of trade or exports
that we do to America which is only
around eight percent China and India
combined is of course around 16
analysts say worsening relations between
East and West accelerating the expansion
of bricks and that seems Clear With
Friends of the block joining the talks
in Cape Town and they include several
African States Saudi Arabia and Iran
famide Al Jazeera Cape Town